and finally new roles someone must
explain to Democrats what binary means
in America we've got dozens of flavours
of pretty much everything Doritos and
Gatorade Oreos Pepsi Triscuits pop-tarts
but we only have two political parties
most democracies have a parliamentary
system with many parties we don't we
don't with us it's always plain or
peanut
[Applause]
creamer suppository that's
that is what binary means Trump gets it
if you really like Donald Trump that's
great but if you don't you have to vote
for me anyway whether you love me or
hate me they got a vote for me the
question Democrats must ask themselves
is what would make a voters say Trump's
right I don't like him but I have no
choice well let's go down the list
Bernie Sanders says we should let the
Boston Marathon bomber vote why is there
a great clamoring to give deranged
serial killers more of a voice in civil
society is Hannibal Lecter thinking I
love Trump for his narcissistic
personality disorder but Sanders really
gets voters like me now I'm sure you can
make an argument for this but we're
trying to win an election here and this
just feeds into what Trump is selling
Democrats are now the party of crazy
politicians crazy Democrats they're
crazy they're crazy
hey Democrats don't make him believable
on that and you win
elizabeth warren has not come out in
favor of imprisoned serial killers
voting but she doesn't want taxpayers to
cover their sex change operations in
prison which brings up the question if
you tried could you come up with a
policy with more third-rail buzzwords in
it
let's see taxpayer-funded sex change for
prisoners no I don't think you could
again where are the votes in this you
know how many transgender people there
are in federal prison in America four
hundred and seventy three and they can't
vote so we're taking this position
because it makes a great campaign slogan
commit a crime and get a free dick
commit a crime and your new vagina is
free so let's imagine a slightly
different scenario you're a progressive
voter who likes Elizabeth Warren you
drive a Prius hate guns and buy kale in
bulk but you find out that Warren does
not support taxpayer-funded gender
reassignment surgery for convicts so
that's it deal-breaker you're voting for
Trump now of course not this is the
binary thing Democrats don't get because
apparently they never saw the movie an
officer and a gentleman we're a drill
sergeant forces Richard Gere to admit
the same truth the Democratic voters
need to face
[Applause]
yes you hear that Bernie and Elizabeth
and Beto and the rest of them they got
nowhere else to go so you can stop
wearing your most divisive issues on
your sleeve target sells condoms and
lube but they don't call it the condom
and lube store they hide that [ __ ] in
the back of their lock case and call
themselves Target
which frankly is not much better point
is instead of trying to make the people
on the far left double dog like you make
some good people in the middle not hate
you people talk people talk a lot in
this country about identity politics
here's some identity for you only 46% of
Democrats identify as liberals yeah life
doesn't end east of La Brea
[Applause]
federal Roark wants to tax churches so
do I but I'm not running for president
Beto wants to take away the tax-exempt
status of any church that opposes gay
marriage a position I doubt goes down
well among black churchgoers and try
winning as a Democrat without them I'm
sure Tyler Perry would vote for Beto
I'm not so sure about Medea I'm not sure
why Kamala Harris felt the need to start
off a recent Town Hall by saying my
pronouns are she her and hers as opposed
to Trump's which are me myself and I now
for some I guess that makes her the Rosa
Parks of pronouns but there's a much
larger group thinking why is this
important why in the first debate did
who leon castro filled the need to take
a brave stand in favor of trans female
abortion rights trans females can't even
get pregnant they don't have a uterus
unless they're in prison and elizabeth
warren buys them warm
this should be easy just be less crazy
than Donald Trump are you guys seriously
struggling with this
69% of voters say they dislike Trump
personally and there's no sign anything
can change their minds but Democrats
reaction to that is ok but let's try let
me help you you don't need to be 100%
Twitter approved on every issue Twitter
is not America most of America most of
America all they want is to vote for
someone who's not weird play to them and
stop worrying that you're gonna lose
social justice warriors to Donald Trump
what is it again Richard Gere I got
nowhere else to go
you